let's try it out. Here is our average program. If we just enter q immediately
then it tells us NaN but what does NaN mean? let's ask everybody on the
Internet. let's search for java NaN. Looks like other people have had this
question before and under the answers it says NaN stands for not a number. It's
produced if some floating point operation has some input parameters that cause
the operation to produce some undefined result. For example, 0 divided by 0 is
arethmatically undefined. So we must have done some kind of math that was
undefined. It seems like the most complicated piece of math we're doing here is
just this division. So let's print out what sum and count are. Here's a print
line statement from sum and count. And now, if I enter q immediately, it tells
me that sum and count are both 0. So it makes sense that I'm getting NaN; I'm
dividing by 0.